prêt pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian show via le père de cédric
joue via bonsoir question faut bien
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on connaît désormais entre
guillemets officiellement les derniers
mots de votre fils j'étouffe dix à sept
reprises qui font évidemment en
dramatiquement écho à se prononcer par
djordje floyd aux états unis quel est
votre état d'esprit votre réaction ce
soir bonsoir
bah notre état d'esprit à la famille et
moi on est c'était dur on va prendre ça
on ne la supportait parce que on pensait
bien que cédric était pas mort en muet
par contre qu'il avait affaire à des
sourds puisque ils ont pas entendu
qu'ils disaient cette fois je respire
plus je respire plus je respire plus je
respire plus je respire plus je respire
plus je respire plus je suis père ne pas
m'être trompé ils n'ont pas entendu
parce que maintenant on a appris que
dans la police on embauche à osciller
sourdre qui a pu handicap aujourd'hui
bientôt en grand on
il faudrait peut-être commencer à
embaucher des manchots pour éviter à
quai les tremblements ça veut dire quoi
concrètement
oui la famille on est
je n'ai pas complet pardonnez moi je
pensais que vous avez terminé votre
centrale ils disent qu'ils l'ont pas
entendu non aujourd'hui disent qu'ils
ont pas entendu puisque cédric leur
disais c'est les coups de pied qui
mettait au sol les débattements ce
n'était pas pour se sait comment pour
faire le pour contraindre à son
arrestation c'était parce qu'il
étouffait il est en train de mourir
je précise je leur dis à chaque fois que
je passe sur une antenne que cédric est
mort le 3 janvier il est mort le 3
janvier aux alentours de 10h 10h30 sur
le pavé de paris
il est pas mort à l'hôpital il était
déjà mort cliniquement quand ils
arrivent à l'hôpital il avait plus de
cerveau on a revu en nahar fait démarrer
son coeur parce que c'était c'était
c'était mieux qui meurent à l'hôpital
que sur le pavé ça faisait ça faisait
mauvais genre pour la police ça veut
dire clairement christian souvient que
il ya eu une forme de manipulation et
voilà qu'on a à cacher des choses
clairement dans la mort de votre fils se
trompent depuis 2 depuis depuis le début
qu'il est parti de bureaux du gong euros
les tels daniel voit depuis 9h20 qu'il
est parti il a eu à 9h45 je crois qu'ils
l'ont interpellé et à 10h ou 10h15
puisque ça a duré 22 minutes et voir
plus qu'il est décédé
de ce moment là le tissu de mensonges a
commencé et là ils ont fait une belle
couverture parce que ça n'arrête pas
castaner est inventeur je le répète je
le redis au gouvernement personne se
bouge personne ne veut il est il a voulu
faire arrêter la cuisson blement et
comme d'habitude il a eu tous les
syndicats qui sont révolutionner et à
prendre compte il l'art permis jusqu'au
mois de septembre
voilà c'est à dire jusqu'au mois de
septembre on peut encore avoir des morts
à cause de laquelle étranglement voilà
je suis pas d'accord mais ma famille mes
enfants mes petits enfants
ma fille ma femme on n'est pas d'accord
son épouse ait pas d'accord qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
faut arrêter la clé d'étranglement faut
arrêter le placage ventrale moi je vais
leur donner une solution puisque plus et
cerveau qu'on fait qu'on fait l'ena
qu'on fait tout ça il n'arrive pas à
comprendre il suffit de le contrôler et
de prendre son nom son adresse
parce qu'il a donné ces documents il a
donné ses papiers il est en règle
ils ont mis une amende je crois ou deux
je sais pas s'ils ont mis des pv mais
j'ai pas encore le rapport mais il a il
a donné ses papiers puisqu'ils ont donné
donc il a bien il a pas refusé
d'obtempérer
il a donné ses papiers donc il est en
règle après le nom d'aqeel ils l'ont
cherché non poussé jusqu'à la faute
jusqu'à huit ans à sortir des insultes
aux au point je peux mettre à quatre
pattes et je passais exclusion et la
vulgarité
parce que c'est les mots ont été dits je
pas le faire une pipe voilà ce qu'il a
dit donc si la provocation elle vient de
l'apab cédric où elle vient de l'apeis
faudrait qu'on m'explique là j'ai pris
vous même qui sans chevaux via la
connaissance de l'enregistrement un
produit par par le micro ducasse de
votre fils cédric à aucun moment votre
fils qu'on soit bien clair n'a été
violent madame je donne mais demain je
donne mais demain vous me les coupe et
demain il n'a jamais sorti une
grossièreté une violence de sa part il a
juste dit je vous file parce que je vais
porter plainte
vous n'avez bousculer on m'avait poussé
mais avait insulté je vais porter
plainte
et quand il a dit ça eh ben ils ont
continué à rigoler voilà il ya même là
à la policière qui étaient là qui a dit
un passant qui est en voiture mais
laissez nous tranquilles on a quand même
bien droit de rigoler voilà mais elle
savait pas que dix minutes après l'été
world a envoyé la voyez la rigolade
ruche jusqu'où elle va la rigolade
voyons où on en est aujourd'hui être la
police alors c'est pas tout la police y
est comme ça faut pas non plus à
extrapoler on n'en veut pas la police on
n'est pas des anti policiers et dans
toutes les tailles faut il faut une
police des fouilles police qui soit
juste une police qui quand vous avez
travaillé le matin vous tuer on les
défend on cache tout on dissimule tout
pour pas que vous ayez raison mais là là
ils sont pas veinard c'est que c'est la
première fois que tout est filmé tout
est filmé donc là ils vont avoir du mal
à se défendre
c'est là que nous aujourd'hui on crie
haut et fort que il faut qu'il faut que
ces gens là payent payent l'addition de
tout ce qui a été fait avant vous
demandez aujourd'hui une requalification
de l'information judiciaire
oui voilà
oui on demande à ce que ça soit
volontaire et pas involontaire c'est pas
un accident c'est un mot que aujourd'hui
on peut pas employer dans la sphère de
mon fils on peut pas dire c'est un
accident
il était coursier s'il avait eu un
accident il ya un camion qui lui sera il
y aurait roulé dessus
c'était différent c'était un accident un
accident bain professionnel parce que
c'est un métier dangereux
là c'est pas un accident professionnel
c'est un contrôle car qui aujourd'hui a
mal tourné parce que il ya eu deux trois
ou quatre personnes qu'on dit à un
moment donné on s'arrête pas on va pas
s'arrêter
il est devenu tout noir il était bleu
quand ils sont arrêtés était bleu et
respirait plus il était mort
cliniquement mort une lampe et pomper
pour essayer de réparer leurs conneries
et quand ils ont dit ils ont un pilon to
fail l'ont sauvé ils ont sauvé quoi
comme vous avez pu le cerveau est pas
sauvé vous êtes à légumes
qu'on ne dise pas le mot on essaie on
l'a sauvé c'est ce qui est employée
aujourd'hui on l'a sauvée mais qu'est-ce
que mais qu'est-ce qu'on comment on peut
dire ça on l'a sauvé ils ont rien sauver
du tout il était mort cliniquement ça
faisait déjà plus trois ou quatre
minutes que le coeur battait plus qu
avait plus rien que sa vérité sans
oxygène elle est où elle est où
aujourd'hui la la la logique de ces gens
là merci
ils ont essayé de réparer leurs bavures
plusieurs vous pouvez qui redémarre qu
un quart des rares merci beaucoup
christian olszowiak père de cédric je
viens d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage de cette réaction